[Music]
apex legend celebrates its first
birthday with the start of season 4
assimilation
if you haven't played the game since it
launched you're in for quite the
surprise if you decide to jump in now
with apex legends going into its year -
we figured it was the perfect time to
look back and see just how much the game
has changed on February 4th 2019 respawn
revealed its new titanfall game was not
actually titanfall 3 as many expected
instead we were getting a free to play
battle royale that takes place within
the titanfall universe it was called
apex legends a fun little nod to Titan
Falls BLISK and his apex predators and
then responded something rather odd it
said the game was now out just
immediately ready to download on Xbox
one ps4 and PC no fanfare no year-long
campaign of trailers and conference
appearances just an announcement and
release and that somehow someway worked
apex legend sought 25 million players
within its first week with two million
peak concurrent users like titanfall 2
the shooting and movement mechanics and
map design were solid fans fell in love
with the diverse cast of characters as
well as the welcome improvements respawn
made to the battle royale formula with
the ping system and hero abilities were
there bugs to fix and balancing changes
to implement sure but apex legends
offered enough to keep players coming
back those first few weeks on February
13th respawn released an update that
included limited time Valentine's Day
themed cosmetics our first hint that
apex legends would do in game
celebrations for certain holidays a week
later on February 20th apex legends got
its first new weapon the havoc assault
rifle those first week suggested respawn
would regularly update the game with new
content and fans began eagerly waiting
for something more did this mean a
battle passives a minute challenges not
yet a month after apex legends released
respawn announced the game had 50
million players and the developer
released a video thinking it's community
the video also jokingly poked fun at the
Mozambique shotgun which was apex
legends worst gun at lot
if anything it seems to suggest respawn
was at least listening to its community
and working on the problems that fans
were bringing up but the novelty of the
game began to wane around this time apex
legend still had no challenges or battle
past a speaker there wasn't really
anything to strive for other than just
getting better at the game
apex legends would finally get a battle
pass on March 19th with the start of
season 1 wild frontier the first season
added a new character to Achtung the
backstory of the idiotic daredevil
provided a nostalgic tied to titanfall 2
when speedrunners tried to break the
record on the titan pilot gauntlet his
abilities weren't exactly game-changing
but Octane's playfully reckless
personality still makes him one of the
most enjoyable add-ons to apex legends
apex legend still didn't have challenges
though and without challenges it was
very difficult to level up in the battle
Paz granted that first pass didn't have
the best rewards anyway in the following
weeks respawn would go on to implement
gameplay adjustments like a new
fortified passive perk for Gibraltar
encaustic as well as bug fixes but
nothing substantial unless you were on
PC of course respawn used this time to
put a serious dent in the hackers and
cheaters that had been dominating the PC
version of the game months would go by
this long dry spell would see some
players drop the game including me if
I'm being honest eleven weeks after the
start of wild frontier apex legends
finally got new content
June 4th saw the start of wild frontiers
first and only limited time event
legendary hunt the event made it easier
to level up in wild frontiers battle
pass better yet it provided a good
reason to even buy the pass in the first
place battle fest owners could nab some
sweet-looking legendary rewards during
legendary hunt players came back it was
the shot in the arm that apex legends
needed before season 2 started respawn
also began fleshing out apex legends
story on June 8th respawn released the
first of its stories from the Outlands a
collection of animated shorts on June
12th the apex legends Twitter account
made its first story focused week
marking the point when the account would
occasionally adopt the persona of a news
anchor that existed within the titanfall
apex Legends universe small map changes
also
and hinting at upcoming story
developments on June 27th respawn
released the cinematic trailer for apex
legend season 2 battle charge which
confirmed a mysterious hacker was taking
an interest in the apex games and the
Flyers and leviathans were now invading
the arena battle charge began on July
2nd implementing the game's first major
map changes it also added a new
character and weapon a pattern all
subsequent seasons would take new
character Watson was a game-changing
addition to apex legends the game's true
first defender Watson could easily lock
down his own and outright negate the
abilities of certain characters she's
still a dominant force on the
competitive side of the game battle
charge was a turning point for apex
legends not only did it finally deliver
on daily and weekly challenges it
introduced a battle pass with worthwhile
rewards rank was also added as a
permanent mode in both in-game events
and cinematic trailers further fleshed
out apex legends lore there was always
something to do during battle charge
whether that was a new lemon-thyme the
vent to play new story details to
discuss or battle past levels to earn
that said battle charge wasn't all
positive during the iron crown
collection event apex legends had a
microtransaction controversy the events
cosmetics were initially solely tied to
loot boxes that did not make people
happy so respawn quickly implemented a
hotfix that made it so you could buy the
events cosmetics individually as well
that seemed to work people stopped
grumbling about the loot boxes since
then respawn has always implemented this
system every event that has cosmetics
and loot boxes allows you to straight up
just by individual cosmetics - if you
don't want to take the chance battle
charge was followed by meltdown which
introduced the long T's crypto as a
playable character another new weapon
and once again implemented challenges
and a battle pass whatever instead of
map changes apex legends got a whole new
map world's edge that fundamentally
altered how teams had to work together
to win the new worlds edge map
emphasized movement more so than the
original Kings Canyon the most surefire
way to find high tier loot was to chase
down the moving train or shoot down one
of the flying cargo BOTS to find a key
to a vault because of the maps larger
size you also had to typically account
for traveling a longer distance when the
ring began to shrink it suddenly became
much more important to have a
on your team who could quickly get your
squad from one spot to another not every
player liked the change but world's edge
and to a greater sense all of season 3
was an example of how respawn was
willing to experiment with apex legends
formula the halloween-themed Fighter
fright event showcased how apex legends
might look with two maps at once the
Christmas themed holiday bash introduced
apex legends first game mode that wasn't
a battle royale and the Roaring Twenties
themed grand soiree arcade saw seven
modes rotated into the game some of
which offered very new ways to play
which brings us to season four
assimilation in the start of year two a
lot sure has changed but what makes apex
legends so fun is still the same that
Chase to be number one
if you're having trouble with your own
journey to becoming a legend GameSpot
has videos on how to play with year ones
11 characters and more guides on the way
for apex legends season 4
[Music]